happy Monday reject nation Greg here
John here we are going to watch the
official trailer for Mary Poppins
returns there's a lot of hype around
this movie John grew up on Mary Poppins
I swear I didn't
so I'm full sugar [ __ ] you got the two
kids are gonna appreciate that Jeff you
have two audience members movie has
skated to the guy in the late 20s who
hasn't seen Mary Poppins and the guy in
the late 20s who has seen Mary Poppins
it's Christopher Robin all over again at
the end this video I want to give a very
special shout out to patron name David
Waterhouse he told me his life story and
I really wanted to share it and I think
it's an important story to share keep a
lookout for that the end of this video
I honestly can't remember why we kept
much neater stuff to begin with are you
still uh flying that with mother and
father those days are long behind me
it's just like Christopher Robert
they're all thrown up and they're not
kids anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you see hardly who have aged at all
really one David discusses a woman's age
Michael would have hoped I taught you
better
[Music]
after all this time same thing that
brought me the first time we've come to
look after the banks children yes that's
sad they have the pipes there we go
yeah dang
[Music]
so you've been opening the children's
heads with nonsense it's just like
Christopher Robin new formula for this
kind of Disney movie Colin Firth and
Meryl Streep
[Music]
I don't know if you guys caught it in
our reaction but we think this is kind
of similar to Christopher Robin just a
little bit just a little bit you know
the way that they they grew up in life
is hard now yeah they suck at being
adults and they forgot what it's like to
be children and they need some kind of
whimsical childhood force to come back
and remind them what it's about
yeah although what I'll give this is
there was a point halfway through the
trailer where he got very Disney bright
and from the images I remember from
seeing song and dance numbers from Mary
Poppins like when he mixes and the
animated colors in the world I wasn't
expecting that because I saw the teaser
trailer on my own and then I'm watching
this I was like oh they're bringing all
this back to ya and that was the stuff
that I just hadn't thought about from
the last teaser cuz it's not there at
all and yeah that really dazzled me in
this trailer and now from at least where
I'm sitting moments later I'm like oh
this movie has to do is be good because
it looks like it has every element I
would have expected from a Mary Poppins
Returns kind of movie I love just seeing
that splicing of animation what looks
like anyway 2d animation with live
action like that really took me back and
all the lighting and the musical numbers
and stuff like that it looks beautiful
it really does I mean as opposed to keep
comparing but come on I came out very
reason you can compare you in the same
studio with Christopher Robin it did
have kind of this gloomy look over it
through most of it is and that's
intentional and that's kind of the point
of it because you're interested for
Robin shoes what I like about the
marketing of this is they're not only
showing you that side of the adulthood
where it's all dark and everything you
will get to the point where there's
musical numbers there's dance numbers
there's a lot of vibrant colors and
everything so it will have that Disney
polish that awesome Flair that you're
looking for because I don't know just
kind of sticking with the darkness
element wasn't really intriguing me all
that much especially because we just saw
Christopher Robin weirdly enough when it
got to that part I was like oh this
actually looks really nice yeah yeah one
of the thing is to like even though it
has a similar jumping-off point from
Christopher Robin this looks like it'll
be much broader much more expansive much
more lively I'm excited to see what
lin-manuel Miranda brings to this to
like he actually got a couple lines of
dialogue in this
I don't always love Rob Marshall's
direction so I hope that his capturing
of the musical numbers sighs is the best
way yeah definitely I mean I liked the
look of what I saw here so I hope that
he you know does a lot of wide capturing
instead of a lot of close-up capturing
of especially the song and dance numbers
because that's a big part of what makes
the originals so timeless and memorable
is a lot of very memorable songs and
dance numbers and the most memorable
dance image I got was a Dick Van Dyke
yeah that's which was cool oh you know
yeah the Dick Van Dyke imagery in there
I've badger Meryl Streep fairly gonna be
in this from Meryl Streep Emily Blunt
both worked with him on into the woods
hmm which is a movie I walked out of
very much excited it's good
understanding when I was watching it
this looks way more enjoyable yeah yeah
definitely looks like at least again
given as much as the trailer can give
you it looks like they are really going
all out in recapturing the style the
magic the scope the look the feel of
Mary Poppins I think it was smart for
them to do the trailer or the way they
did it like this because this is not a
comparison to the movie per se I'm just
talking about the box office is the box
office I'm mr. Christopher Robin weren't
all that good all things considered
coming from Disney it wasn't just
crossed a billion yeah second highest
grossing movie of all time it wasn't
necessarily a flop but it wasn't exactly
like bringing in gigantic box office
Disney numbers I think you got to make a
trailer that can capture both the
nostalgia factor and also rack in a new
audience for people yeah I think this
trailer has the capability to not just
for someone like myself but the primary
audience which is children and you know
yeah for if this I think a trailer like
this is a lot more appealing to kids
then kind of the gloomy side of things
that Robin presented its style teasers
yeah this is definitely not to dumb
everything down but it's just yeah so
much brighter and so much more under
jeddak yeah so and how my blood looks
great she does she looks amazing I mean
everybody in the cast is I think but
even in the gloomy side of things there
seems to be a little bit of a whimsy to
the way a lot of the dialogues being
handled you get the sense that it is a
different doesn't really mean dark like
even though that's a gloomy London
weather doesn't feel like it's gonna be
this dark film at all just with some
real-life stakes yeah emotional weight
perhaps yeah not necessarily darkness
but yeah that looks really delightful
you know in December I'm excited it's
just like one of the few films right on
December busy alright guys well what do
you guys think of this Mary Poppins
Returns trailer are you someone who grew
up on the original is really looking
forward to this do you like John
Krasinski comment below do you wish he
was in this yeah I want to give a page
from the day shout-out to a man named
David Waterhouse on our patreon he's
called David bloody fury Waterhouse
that's right kids and if I'm not
mistaken he is from the UK I talked to
him for a while and then I come to find
out his life story and I asked if I
could share it he was a prostitute so
while we're talking to messages he
mentioned a couple of things about
having a limited capacity to walk so I
decided to ask him about it a while ago
he told me his story and I'm gonna read
from it said he was run over by a
double-decker bus and got dragged up
into the wheel arch and dragged a bit
down the road you know with spinal and
nerve damage plus shards of bone lodged
in his spinal column involuntary muscle
spasms all over and constantly in pain
as he has an extreme tolerance the
medication even morphine no longer works
for him yeah because of this process he
actually his marriage ended up kind of
falling apart because you know it's like
that's a really hard thing to have to
deal with it becomes kind of the center
of life after that and he doesn't have
any like bitter feelings towards her but
unfortunately had to move like 70 miles
away from the wife and daughter he was
actually told he'd never be able to walk
again but through sheer determination of
working through the pain he's been able
to walk with certain aids like crutches
and whatever he's lost 240 pounds in the
process yeah even though he still
considers himself a big guy he's lost a
lot of weight he's also been able to
kick cigarettes and he's able to walk so
a lot of things he was told he wasn't
able to do he's been able to overcome
accomplished and he actually told me
that his daughter Rosie Lai watches this
channel as well oh that the main thing
he's been looking forward to is being
able to have a holiday with his daughter
it's a Rosie Lai thank you for watching
our channel you're someone that he loves
to rave about think he's most
anticipating as being able to go on a
first holiday trip with you and he loves
the hell out of you and we love your dad
and because we love your daddy because
you watch our channel we love you bye
by extension love you it only go stands
to reason it's stories like yours David
that I find truly inspiring here's
someone who will hit us up being like
hey I was going through the recovery
process you guys were an inspiration
help me out and gave us a lot of laughs
which I appreciate but on this version
of the story when I hear what you had to
go through and what you've had to
overcome you're someone who encourages
me to never give up and to keep going no
matter what yes and to have a positive
mentality it's easy to fall into a
negative side based off circumstances
but sometimes when you're put in a live
or die situation you choose to live and
you overcome it so thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks for allowing
us to share what you've gone through
it's it's weird when you get to know
some of the people who watch your
channel and a lot of them have insane
stories just like you did but so thanks
for sharing yeah no I mean those stories
help others too you know alright guys
well thank you for watching you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation please
click that notification bellow get
notified every time one of our bids is
up and you can check us on patreon we
got full-length TV show reactions q and
A's and occasional music video coverage
we'd love to have you become a patron
check today